-Higgins,
you were talking earlier
and you said that you don't find
math interesting.
-No, not at all.
[ Laughter ]
-You find math boring.
-Boring, yeah. Bo-ring!
-Yes.
Well, I wanted to help you out.
-Thank you.
-So what what I've done is
I've updated math
to make the equations be
about stuff
that we all can relate to.
-Oh.
-Yeah, it's time
for "Popular Mathematics."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Popular ♪
♪ Mathematics ♪
-Love it.
-I still say that is our best
-Yeah.
-song.
-It's up there.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-♪ Popular ♪
♪ Mathematics ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-So good.
-That is up.
-It's a different level.
-Yeah.
-We're doing
"Popular Mathematics."
-Thank God.
-Yeah, this is it.
Take a look
at this first equation here.
If you take...
[ Laughter and applause ]
You understand?
-Yeah.
-Here's another one...
-Oh.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Because when you're there,
you're family.
These are like story problems.
-If you take...
[ Laughter and applause ]
See?
-Singular.
-Here's another one here...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's all it takes.
If you take...
[ Laughter and applause ]
'90s are back!
-Hey, man.
-Here's another one...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"I need a shirt!
I can't see!"
-If you take...
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's just make it
exciting for you, yeah.
-Yeah, because I love it.
-Yeah. Here's another one...
[ Cheering and applause ]
And, finally...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's all the time we have
for "Popular Mathematics."